J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, alors que le soleil nous assomme tous et que la canicule est telle que même penser devient moite, j'ai eu envie de parler de rire.
Vous connaissez ma passion pour la déconstruction, la dissection des mécaniques qui composent notre société, que ce soit les questions de genre, de politique, de psychologie, de sociologie.
Et parmi les épisodes qui incarnaient particulièrement bien cette approche transversale, il y en a un qui, il y a cinq ans, presque six, avait été particulièrement apprécié, c'était mon entretien avec Olivia Gazalé.
Olivia publiait l'an dernier Le Paradoxe du rire, un essai qui démonte l'illusion d'un rire innocent, car on ne rit jamais juste pour rire.
Le rire peut exclure, désarmer, renverser, humilier ou souder et prend toujours place dans un contexte, dans des logiques sociales, morales ou politiques.
Cinq ans après notre première conversation sur le mythe de la virilité, je la retrouve pour explorer, disséquer et analyser ensemble la mécanique de phénomènes spécifiquement humains : le rire, l'humour, l'ironie, le sarcasme.
Ça a été à nouveau un authentique plaisir que de croiser la route d'un esprit aussi atypique qui aime autant que moi explorer et analyser les choses.
Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute et que cette conversation vous fasse rire, repenser les choses ou peut-être même les deux à la fois.
J'ai le plaisir de retrouver Olivia. Bonjour Olivia.
Bonjour Guillaume.
J'ai, comme je le disais, l'immense joie de te retrouver. Ça fait 2019, c'est ça hein, donc...
Il me semble que ça fait, ouais, c'est ça...
Six ans.
Oui.
Je ne les ai pas vus passer.
Mais non, mais on n'a pas pris une ride, toi et moi.
Certainement pas. Donc on avait fait un podcast ensemble il y a six ans pour parler du mythe de la virilité, ton essai précédent.
Mmm-hmm.
Où tu explorais en long et en large, en profondeur. C'est presque une démarche d'anthropologue, finalement, ce que tu avais fait à l'époque où vraiment, tu traversais l'histoire humaine et tu essaies de déconstruire les choses.
C'était transdisciplinaire.
Tout à fait, oui, oui. Et c'est un petit peu la même démarche que tu opères...
Exactement.
...cette fois-ci.
Mais cette fois-ci, tu te concentres sur le rire, sur l'humour, sur le sarcasme. Et c'est effectivement une des questions, voilà, qui, de la même manière qu'on parle beaucoup des questions de genre, on parle beaucoup des questions de,
de déconstruire la virilité, la masculinité toxique, le féminisme, etc.
C'est vrai que dans l'actualité de ces dernières années, mais pas seulement ces dernières années, on en reparlera, on parle beaucoup du : est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout ?
De qu'est-ce qui passe ? Qu'est-ce qui ne passe pas ? Est-ce qu'une blague est problématique ou pas ?
Et donc, finalement, voilà, c'est la question à laquelle tu touches plutôt vers la fin de ton essai, du type : peut-on rire de tout sans blesser personne ?
Que tu qualifies un petit peu de, d'insoluble ou de pas facilement... C'est pas un problème simple. C'est ça que tu dis.
Ah non, c'est tout sauf simple. C'est tout sauf simple. La difficulté, c'est que quand on demande : peut-on rire de tout ?
Si on répond oui, on peut rire de tout, on peut risquer de blesser des personnes sensibles ou vulnérables. Mais si on répond non, alors on va faire le jeu de la censure.
Et puis à partir de quel moment on peut dire ou ne pas dire. Bref, moi, j'ai essayé de répondre à cette question, en disant oui, on peut rire de tout, il faut rire de tout, de tous et de tout
et de toutes, mais à condition que ce soit fait avec humour.
Et donc ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans ce livre, c'est de définir, enfin de définir, en tout cas de cerner au plus près ce qu'était l'humour.
Parce qu'en fait, on a tendance à ne pas distinguer trois concepts qui sont souvent mélangés, c'est le rire, le comique et l'humour. Et en fait...
Ah, je pensais que tu allais dire le sarcasme.
Oui, mais j'y viens. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, le rire, c'est un effet, c'est une réaction organique à partir d'un stimulus.
Ok ? Le comique, c'est la cause du rire, c'est une des causes du rire, c'est un des stimuli qui peut provoquer le rire. Parce que par exemple, les chatouilles, ce n'est pas du comique.
Le comique, ça va être de produire un contenu, un énoncé, que ce soit une blague, un dessin, une plaisanterie, un trait d'esprit, dans le but de provoquer le rire.
C'est ça le comique. Et l'humour, c'est une des formes que prend le comique. Et donc par opposition, par exemple, au sarcasme.
Et donc, je pense qu'on peut opposer facilement l'humour, qui a une dimension ludique, d'autodérision, de rupture avec l'esprit de sérieux,
au sarcasme qui, lui, vise vraiment à une finalité qui est la dénonciation et qui inspire, enfin, le sarcasme, il vise à provoquer une sorte de dénigrement de son objet...
C'est une démarche...
...voire une humiliation. Voilà.
...plus offensive. Oui.
Beaucoup plus offensive. Alors que pour moi, l'humour, c'est justement, on va avoir l'occasion de préciser, parce que pour moi, c'est un art, c'est très difficile de faire de l'humour.
C'est comme un funambule qui est sur une ligne de crête extrêmement étroite.
Il suffit d'une seconde de plus, d'un ton un petit peu différent, etc., pour que ça passe ou que ça ne passe pas exactement comme un peintre qui aurait mis un peu trop de rouge à un endroit et du coup, le tableau est raté.
Et effectivement avec l'humour, on est toujours sur une ligne extrêmement étroite entre drôle et pas drôle. Et c'est ça que j'ai voulu explorer dans mon livre.
Oui, oui, effectivement, quand tu dis un exercice de funambule, un équilibre particulièrement difficile à trouver. Et pourquoi aujourd'hui, pourquoi maintenant ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu un élément déclencheur qui t'a ramené sur ce sujet-là en particulier ?
Alors pas spécifiquement récemment parce qu'en fait, il y a eu des affaires liées au rire qui sont sorties, mais une fois que mon livre était déjà publié, donc ça l'a accompagné parce que toute ma promo a été obnubilée.
On ne pouvait pas faire une interview sans qu'on parle des affaires Guillaume Meurice par exemple. Mais en fait quand je me suis mise à travailler, c'était plutôt quelque chose que je, un sujet que je portais en moi depuis très longtemps.
Parce que même, je pense depuis l'adolescence, parce qu'en fait personnellement, j'adore rire, j'ai le rire très facile, j'ai tendance à pas mal vanner mon entourage, donc forcément quand on vanne, on se fait vanner.
Et je parfois, enfin, je faisais cette expérience que, qui est très ordinaire, donc que tout le monde a faite, c'est-à-dire que tout à coup, vous recevez une plaisanterie qui vous vexe, voire qui vous humilie.
Donc, vous répondez : bah, c'est pas très drôle. Et là, la personne qui vous a fait la blague vous dit : oh, mais ça va, c'est de l'humour.
Et en fait à chaque fois, je restais complètement, on reste complètement muet quand on... parce qu'on se fait attaquer deux fois en fait.
Une première fois parce qu'on a pris une vanne un peu humiliante, un peu dégradante et on est humilié, on est offensé.
Et la deuxième fois parce qu'en plus, on s'entend dire qu'on n'a pas d'humour. Et ça fait longtemps que ça me gênait cette chose-là.
Je me disais, mais en fait,
j'avais envie de leur dire, mais non, ce n'est pas de l'humour. Et en fait, je crois que j'ai écrit ce livre pour donner des armes aux personnes à qui ça arrive, qui se prennent ce,
une plaisanterie désagréable dans la figure, pour qu'elles puissent répondre : ah non non non, je suis désolée, là, ce n'était pas de l'humour, c'était du sarcasme.
Je vais t'expliquer la différence entre humour et sarcasme. Et en fait, tu vas comprendre que c'est toi qui n'as pas d'humour.
Parce que ce n'était pas de l'humour là, c'était de l'attaque. Donc comment distinguer une blague qui est offensive d'une blague qui ne l'est pas ?
C'est tous les paramètres que j'ai essayé de déconstruire parce qu'en fait l'humour et le rire, c'est jamais une affaire d'énoncé, c'est une affaire d'énonciation.
C'est-à-dire que le même contenu dans un contexte ou dans un autre, dit par une personne ou par une autre, en présence d'une personne ou d'une autre ou pas, n'a pas la même signification, ce n'est pas le même acte d'expression.
Et en fait, c'est ça qui est intéressant, c'est de définir à quelles conditions une blague peut être qualifiée d'humour ou pas.
Oui, c'est donc vraiment une question,
vraiment une question de contexte, de perspective.
En fonction de la perspective de la personne qui énonce la blague, on peut percevoir ça comme quelque chose de choquant, mais surprise positive, surprise inattendue, mais du coup voilà, surprise bénigne, on va dire.
Oui.
Et inversement, si la personne dit ça d'un point de vue, d'une perspective ne convient pas pour dire ça comme ça, ça peut déranger très fort.
Et c'est souvent soit l'un soit l'autre. On est soit, soit on rigole, soit on est dérangé. On est rarement...
Indifférent.
Voilà, oui.
Oui, parce qu'en fait, tout le problème vient du fait que pour déclencher l'hilarité, pour faire rire, en fait, il faut heurter.
Il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose qui nous surprenne, tu l'as dit, voire qui nous dérange, qui nous heurte. En fait, pour déclencher l'hilarité, il faut transgresser toujours une norme.
Donc, il faut outrepasser les limites. Il faut être dans l'excès, il faut être dans la caricature ou il faut... Tu vois quand je dis qu'il faut transgresser une norme, ça peut être une norme du langage.
Quand tu fais un calembour, un jeu de mots, tu transgresses une norme du langage. Ça peut être, tu transgresses les normes de la bienséance quand tu fais une vanne un peu obscène ou scatologique ou sexuelle ou que sais-je.
Ça peut être une norme de la logique quand tu fais du non-sens. Bref, il y a toujours quelque chose, un ordre qui est subverti.
Et donc c'est là qu'effectivement réside la difficulté. C'est que si tu te passes de la subversion, si tu cherches quelque chose de lisse, eh ben en fait, tu ne vas pas faire rire, tu ne vas pas déclencher l'hilarité.
Et c'est tout cet équilibre qui est compliqué à trouver.
Oui oui. Et donc tu explores ces questions-là à travers les époques. C'est plutôt centré sur l'Occident, sur la France.
Oui.
Mais c'est voilà, c'est vraiment...
Non, les États-Unis aussi, le monde anglais. L'Occident, on va dire.
L'Occident, oui oui. Mais donc voilà, à travers les prismes politiques, historiques, religieux aussi.
Oui.
Voilà, c'est du Olivia Gazalé. Ça rappelle ta démarche avec le mythe de la virilité.
Oui, tout à fait. T'es le premier à le souligner, mais effectivement pour moi, c'est toujours la même démarche. C'est-à-dire que quand je cherche à
à étudier un sujet, en fait le rire comme les questions de genre, la virilité, ce sont des constructions culturelles.
Donc en fait, on ne peut pas étudier une construction culturelle sans l'aborder sous tous les angles, c'est-à-dire historique, anthropologique, sociologique, psychologique, psychanalytique, même littéraire.
Et donc en fait, moi, c'est ça qui m'intéresse, c'est d'aborder un sujet à la fois sous tous les angles. C'est pour ça que tu m'as interviewée il y a six ans, parce que je mets beaucoup de temps à écrire mes livres.
Donc celui-là, j'ai mis quatre ans. Il est sorti quand même il y a un an et demi. Donc voilà. Et la prochaine fois que tu m'intervieweras, Guillaume, j'espère que je serai toujours là et que j'aurai toujours les dents.
Je serai retraité.
Moi aussi.
Oui, mais donc effectivement, quand on lit ton livre, on voit le nombre de notes en bas de page et de citations.
Oui.
Et on voit que tu as vraiment été te documenter. Tu vas chercher chez Cicéron, tu vas chercher chez
Aristophane.
Oui voilà, c'est ça. Et, enfin, je veux dire dans les comiques new-yorkais juifs, dans...
Voilà.
Dans le, voilà, l'histoire contemporaine, le Moyen Âge, la Renaissance. Tu fais un travail vraiment de documentaliste, d'historienne, oui.
C'est pour ça que j'ai employé le mot d'anthropologue tout à l'heure.
Oui oui, tout à fait. Je...
Et c'est intéressant parce que le rire,
c'est justement plutôt quelque chose, parce que toi, tu dis quand on veut essayer de comprendre les choses, il faut déconstruire sur tous les aspects, sur tous les angles, il faut travailler, etc.
Et j'ai l'impression que pour, j'ai envie de dire la plupart des gens, les gens qui ne sont pas Olivia Gazalé, et qui ne sont pas Guillaume Hachez, c'est le rire, ça fait partie des choses qui sont dans,
c'est implicitement une évidence, ça n'est pas être remis en question.
Les mécaniques sont intuitives. Voilà, pour dire ça comme ça. Et toi, avec cette démarche, avec ce livre, j'ai l'impression que tu te penches sur ces questions en disant : mais en fait non, tout ça n'est pas clair.
Oui, absolument. En fait, déjà, on a tendance à penser que le rire est toujours anodin et inoffensif et insignifiant, que c'est juste un petit agrément dans la vie comme ça, on rit.
Bon. Et en fait, on se rend compte qu'il y a
des rires, il y a différents types de rires. Il y a, évidemment, des rires qui sont des rires ludiques, des rires de joie, des rires qu'on va qualifier de salutaires ou de positifs.
Même, on a des rires de protection. Il y a parfois des rires tout simplement qui sont des, qui ont une fonction un peu anxiolytique devant les choses qui sont...
Mh.
Terrifiantes comme la mort, les enterrements, on rit dans les enterrements. Il y a quelque chose de très libérateur.
Oui, tout à fait oui. J'ai connu des gens qui s'esclaffaient et qui rigolaient, même quand il n'y avait vraiment rien de particulièrement comique ou de drôle, mais c'était vraiment juste mécaniquement pour évacuer le stress.
On voyait que ces gens rigolaient alors qu'il n'y avait rien de drôle.
Oui oui oui, exactement. Et puis tu as aussi des rires qui sont des rires beaucoup plus offensifs, beaucoup plus exclusifs et qui ont une fonction stratégique, une fonction politique.
Mh.
Donc c'est soit dans l'exclusion, quand tu vois par exemple...
Les blagues sur les Belges, par exemple.
Ou, oui, les blagues sur les Belges ou même quand un enfant se fait harceler en classe, en général, c'est à base de plaisanteries, à base de vannes.
Donc, on voit un rire de meute qui va exclure un individu. Donc là, il y a vraiment quelque chose de...
Mh.
Il y a une fonction stratégique, c'est écraser quelqu'un.
Hiérarchisation.
L'exclure, voilà exactement. Et donc c'est toutes ces différentes facettes qui effectivement, pour répondre à ta question, échappent normalement à notre vigilance.
En fait, si on ne fait pas un effort pour s'y arrêter, oui, le rire ne paraît pas un sujet philosophique.
D'ailleurs, la philosophie s'y est très peu intéressée, hein, indépendamment de Bergson. Ça a été vite renvoyé au rire de moquerie.
Donc les philosophes ont
pas mal dénigré le rire en disant voilà,
le rire est mauvais, le rire, c'est... Enfin, c'est depuis Aristote, hein, qui a expliqué que la tragédie était noble parce qu'elle élève les âmes dans les problématiques métaphysiques, existentielles, nobles, la vie, la mort, l'amour, etc.
Alors que la comédie, ça nous enracine dans l'obscénité, la trivialité, tout ce qui est bas et vil. Et donc cette hiérarchisation, elle a produit des effets dans toute la civilisation occidentale.
Et tu regardes encore aujourd'hui, tu vois rarement des comédies qui sont primées aux César, etc. Ça va être... On va considérer que c'est beaucoup moins noble.
D'ailleurs, les comiques en souffrent, hein, de cette hiérarchisation. En plus, l'Église en a remis une couche, si je peux m'exprimer ainsi, parce que l'Église a renvoyé le rire au péché.
Mh.
Si tu veux, on peut s'attarder dessus parce que c'est vraiment intéressant la conception théologique chrétienne du rire.
Et donc pour toutes ces raisons, on oublie que le rire est une construction culturelle qui a eu une fonction stratégique dans l'histoire au service du pouvoir ou au contraire pour dénoncer le pouvoir.
Oui oui. Comme beaucoup de choses, c'est un mélange entre effectivement une construction culturelle, sociale, politique.
Et, ben en fait, tu ouvres le livre avec quelque chose de très, voilà, tu dissèques le rire presque littéralement. Parce que tu rentres dans le cerveau, tu rentres dans les corps,
et tu commences par casser cette idée que le rire, c'est l'exclusif de l'homme.
Et tu expliques qu'en fait, on peut chatouiller les rats, qu'il se passe déjà quelque chose à ce niveau-là. Tu expliques que nos cousins, les singes, nos cousins simiesques, peuvent aussi rigoler du jeu, s'amuser.
Bien sûr.
Mais que par contre, pour l'humain, c'est... On a l'exclusivité du rire intellectuel, pour dire ça comme ça.
Oui oui oui, absolument. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, ce qui est l'héritage du rire animal chez nous, c'est par exemple le rire des chatouilles ou ce rire de jeu.
Tu regardes des enfants qui jouent à se battre entre eux, ils vont rire. Et en fait, on retrouve exactement le même rire chez les grands singes, surtout les chimpanzés, les bonobos, qui sont nos plus proches cousins. Et,
et on a... Il y a une grande spécialiste du rire animal qui s'appelle Marina Davila Ross à l'université de Portsmouth, qui a étudié le,
ce rire des grands singes pour montrer qu'en fait, il avait une fonction d'apprentissage et de socialisation,
exactement comme le rire chez les petits.
Je vais te donner l'exemple des chatouilles. Souvent, c'est un grand, un plus âgé qui va chatouiller un plus petit. Chez les singes comme chez nous.
Souvent un jeu, pour un adulte, c'est voilà, on va chatouiller un petit. Bon, et le fait que le grand rit en faisant ça ou fasse rire le petit, le rire, en fait, il est là pour signifier : c'est pour de faux.
C'est une parodie d'agression, c'est un simulacre. Je vais pas vraiment te faire de mal, je vais pas te... voilà, je vais juste te chatouiller.
Et le rire est là pour signifier qu'on est dans le non-sérieux.
Ouais, dans l'innocence, ouais.
Voilà, exactement. Et ce que Marina Davila Ross explique, c'est que grâce à ce rire, eh bien, les petits singes, ils apprennent à se défendre.
Parce qu'en fait, les chatouilles, ça a pour but, en milieu sauvage, de t'apprendre à protéger tes parties les plus vulnérables.
Et comme par hasard, les parties qui sont les plus chatouilleuses, les parties du corps, ce sont les plus vulnérables en cas d'agression, donc les aisselles, la plante des pieds, par exemple, les côtes.
Et par ce rire innocent et inoffensif, ce rire de jeu, le petit apprend à se défendre et donc ça signale... Moi, je trouve hyper intéressant de montrer ici que le rire, c'est l'inhibition des pulsions agressives, ça signale ça.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est par extension quand tu joues à un jeu de société, heureusement qu'il y a le rire, parce que le rire aussi, là, signale que c'est pour de rire.
On t'en veut pas vraiment. Tu tombes sur mon... on joue au Monopoly, tu tombes sur mon hôtel rue de la Paix et que je te dis : « Allez, vas-y, paye !
» alors que t'as plus un franc devant toi-
Mh.
...plus un euro. Heureusement qu'il y a le rire, parce que le rire indique que voilà, je ne veux pas vraiment ta ruine.
Je sais que ce n'est qu'un jeu. Donc voilà, c'est intéressant de voir que le rire a été conservé dans l'histoire de l'évolution, pour justement signaler le passage au non-sérieux.
Et souvent, par exemple, une engueulade qui tout à coup il y en a un des deux qui éclate de rire, eh ben c'est fini. Voilà, ça veut dire bon ok, ça va, c'est bon, on passe à autre chose.
Donc il a vraiment cette fonction de dire, on est dans le registre de l'inoffensif. Et encore une fois, si on passe maintenant au rire intellectuel, c'est-à-dire justement à la dimension comique,
c'est-à-dire je cherche à déclencher le rire,
ben là, c'est pareil, si tu es dans l'agression, s'il n'y a pas de... C'est-à-dire que pour déclencher l'hilarité, il faut bien sûr une incongruité, quelque chose qui m'ait dérangé, la transgression d'une norme, une surprise.
C'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure. Mais il y a une condition sine qua non, c'est l'innocuité. C'est-à-dire, ça ne doit pas me faire de mal.
Dès que je suis blessé, dès que je suis attaqué, dès que je pense que l'attaque est sérieuse, je ne ris pas. Je ne peux pas rire.
Et en fait, le rire, c'est toujours la métabolisation d'une émotion. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une émotion qui est... par exemple, dans un enterrement, tu vois, l'émotion négative, elle est là, on est tous accablés par le chagrin
et tout à coup, il va y avoir une petite incongruité, genre, je sais pas, l'officiant qui va faire un lapsus ou une mamie qui se mouche un peu trop fort, etc.
Poum ! Ça surprend. Et toute l'émotion négative, qui est en surcharge, qui est là, qui te bloque en fait la respiration-
Est expurgée.
Est expurgée, exactement, dans ces secousses jouissives de l'abdomen. Donc en fait, c'est une déviation, c'est comme une soupape, un exutoire et tout à coup, tout ce qui était bloqué dans le thorax
qui est coincé comme ça et tout à coup, ça s'évacue.
Et cette évacuation, moi, j'insiste toujours sur le fait que c'est une jouissance.
Mh.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, tu transformes une émotion négative en jouissance.
Oui.
Parce qu'en fait, on rit pas tous des mêmes choses, évidemment, et d'une époque à l'autre, d'une culture à l'autre, d'un âge à l'autre, etc.
En revanche, tout le monde aime rire. On aime tous rire, on ne peut pas ne pas aimer rire, même ceux-
C'est ça
...qui rient peu. C'est une jouissance. Et puis tu sécrètes les hormones-
Des endorphines, de la dopamine.
Exactement. Tu sécrètes les hormones du bien-être. Donc même d'un simple point de vue chimique, si tu ris à un enterrement, tu survis en fait.
C'est comme ça que tu survis à la tristesse. Et d'ailleurs, j'ai montré dans mon livre, j'ai fait des recherches où on rit, on rit en prison, on riait dans les tranchées de Verdun-
Mh.
...on riait même dans les camps de la mort. Parce que rire, c'est une façon un peu de survivre, tout simplement.
C'est pour survivre à la tragédie. Tu trouves une sorte de dérivatif, un exutoire et un peu de plaisir. Voilà, c'est cette dimension du plaisir.
Oui, ce plaisir, cette dopamine, cette endorphine. Tout à fait. Oui, c'est très... Tu disais on ne rigole pas tous des mêmes choses, mais en fait, tu ouvres ce livre et tu nous renvoies
à notre chair et à nos fonctionnements physiologiques.
Parce que ça, c'est universel. Le fait qu'on a cette mécanique de-
Oui.
Voilà, cet influx nerveux qui va effectivement libérer un paquet de dopamine dans nos petites cervelles.
Et effectivement, ça, c'est super jouissif. Et ça, c'est universel, ouais.
C'est universel. Et encore une fois, si le rire a été conservé par l'évolution qui, comme tu sais, a supprimé pas mal de fonctions qui servaient à rien,
si ça a été conservé, si ça a traversé les dizaines de millénaires, les centaines de millénaires depuis la naissance de Sapiens, enfin depuis l'apparition de Sapiens-
Mh.
...c'est que le rire a une fonction, et c'est une fonction vitale.
Oui, oui.
Voilà.
Tu parles des cliniques du rire où, voilà, on fait rentrer des-
Oui
...des clowns dans les hôpitaux pour faire rire les patients et qui autrement, voilà, seraient rapidement très dépressifs-
Exactement
...vu leur état.
Exactement.
Et on voit vraiment des effets très positifs sur leur état de santé. Donc oui, ça tient logique de ce que tu disais sur
ce besoin voilà évolutif qui était, enfin ce mécanisme qui a été conservé au fil des années.
Ce qui n'est pas resté constant par contre, c'est le rapport social, sociétal à l'humour.
Voilà exactement.
Parce que voilà, tu remontes à l'Antiquité, tu me parles de, alors je ne sais plus exactement comment ça s'appelle, les trucs avec Dionysos ?
Alors le rire dionysiaque, oui en fait ça m'a beaucoup intéressée d'aller voir comment riaient les anciens et surtout les fonctions qu'ils attribuaient au rire.
Et en fait, en me penchant dans cette grosse histoire du rire de Georges Minois, un historien qui explique très bien ça
et qui montre qu'il y avait beaucoup de cérémonies, de rituels religieux, de grandes fêtes, ces grandes fêtes archaïques du monde grec où en fait, on riait beaucoup.
Et le rire avait là une fonction, parce qu'il en a plein des fonctions. Mais ce que met bien en valeur Georges Minois, c'est que chez les Grecs, ce rire dionysiaque lors des grandes fêtes,
il avait une fonction de finalement, en fait, de contrôle social, paradoxalement,
parce que lors de ces rituels, le rire d'abord était ritualisé, donc codifié, ça apparaissait pendant des moments précis, notamment pendant une phase qui s'appelait l'orgie, qui était une phase où en fait tout le monde mimait le chaos,
le chaos originel et avec un phénomène, enfin une pratique très intéressante qu'on va retrouver dans les fêtes médiévales aussi,
qui sont les pratiques d'inversion, les pratiques de mascarade, c'est-à-dire l'homme se déguise en femme, inversement, l'esclave se déguise en homme riche.
Et en fait, ce que montre Georges Minois, c'est que la fête n'avait de sens, ce rire n'avait de sens que par sa clôture.
C'est-à-dire, c'est quand la fête n'a de vocation qu'à prendre fin. Parce que quand la fête est finie, on en revient aux hiérarchies traditionnelles, aux rapports de classe, aux rapports de genre, aux rapports de domination.
Et en fait, la fête a servi d'exutoire pendant un temps circonscrit, limité, délimité, programmé, officiel.
On a tous les droits, on rit, c'est la licence absolue, on se moque de toutes les conventions, on renverse toutes les hiérarchies, mais dans le but de raffermir l'ordre et les hiérarchies une fois que la fête est finie.
Donc en fait, on voit que c'est un rire qui est au service du pouvoir, qui est instrumentalisé dans le but de la consolidation du pouvoir.
Et ça, je trouve ça hyper intéressant. D'ailleurs, on le retrouve dans les fêtes religieuses du Moyen Âge hein.
La fête des fous, c'est une fête qui était née dans le cadre de l'Église et qui autorisait les moines à faire les fous, à faire n'importe quoi, même à se déguiser en pape, à élire un roi comique, etc. Le but, c'était que
l'austérité et l'ascèse,
à laquelle on soumettait les moines était tellement insupportable qu'on devait leur octroyer des moments de liesse, des moments où tout était permis
pour pouvoir supporter le reste du temps la discipline carcérale à laquelle les moines étaient tenus.
Donc en fait, j'ai trouvé très intéressant de voir que le rire avait d'abord eu une fonction de contrôle social et de sanction de la déviance aussi.
Ça, c'est une autre fonction qui est très claire au cours de l'histoire, c'est que le rire va sanctionner le déviant, celui qui n'est pas dans la norme, celui qui fait pas comme tout le monde.
On va ricaner et c'est un rire punitif, c'est un rire de sanction. Par exemple, au Moyen Âge, il y avait des peines de pilori ou de charivari quand quelqu'un avait agi, par exemple un mariage mal assorti ou
quelque chose d'un peu répréhensible, mais qu'à l'époque, il n'y avait pas encore forcément toujours de tribunaux.
Donc, il y avait des peines qui étaient administrées par le village. Et donc là, c'était par exemple un mariage mal assorti, peine de charivari.
C'est tout le village qui fait un cortège hyper bruyant jusqu'à la maison des coupables. Et là, pendant des jours, parfois des semaines,
c'est des grosses plaisanteries, on défèque et on urine sur la maison, on leur envoie toutes sortes de quolibets, etc.
Et on se moque. Et en fait, cette moquerie, elle a pour but de châtier la déviance, corriger les mœurs.
Oui, oui. Et on observe un petit peu des mouvements de balancier dans ce sens-là, puisqu'il y a, voilà, tu décrivais vraiment ces diverses formes de moquerie, de chaos, de carnaval, de...
Voilà, on se moque des puissants, on donne l'exemple des conditions très dures, presque carcérales des moines.
Inversement, il y a eu assez régulièrement à travers l'histoire, et c'était déjà le cas puisqu'on parlait de la Grèce antique, des mouvements de répression du rire,
le rire qui n'était pas accepté, qui connaissait des formes de censure, de poursuite.
Ça prenait quelle forme, par exemple, déjà, en Grèce antique ?
Bah alors, en Grèce antique, j'ai pas de,
je n'ai pas d'éléments là-dessus parce que la vraie censure du rire, les vrais interdits portant sur le rire, pour moi, ils datent du christianisme, en tout cas dans l'histoire de l'Occident.
Ah oui. Oui.
Voilà.
Ça, c'est pour la censure à proprement parler, mais pour la répression, il y avait déjà, voilà, les Aristophane qui,
voilà, qui brocardaient les politiciens, les notables, qui suscitaient des réactions vives et parfois, c'était...
Ah oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Ah oui, il y a eu des censures, notamment sous Périclès, où il y a eu effectivement des censures, mais ça...
C'est pas la même chose.
Non, mais parce que ça renvoyait au poète comique, c'est-à-dire que c'était des censures sur les auteurs.
Mais je n'ai pas, en tout cas, connaissance, ça se faisait peut-être, d'une vraie répression sociale du rire dans la vie de tous les jours comme les chrétiens vont l'introduire.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment le christianisme qui va donner cette connotation diabolique au rire et indépendamment des moines, c'est-à-dire pour tout le monde et notamment pour les femmes.
Parce qu'en fait chez les dieux grecs, ils rient. L'Olympe est tout le temps, il y a tout le temps des rires. D'ailleurs, Homère parle d'un rire inextinguible des dieux.
Donc le rire n'a pas encore cette connotation maléfique. Platon se méfie du rire, mais bon, ça reste de la théorie tout ça.
Mais à partir du christianisme, il va y avoir vraiment une, je dirais une sanction morale beaucoup plus lourde sur les rieurs.
Et à mon sens, ça vient du fait que les théologiens, les grands pères de l'Église, les premiers grands théologiens qui vont donc construire au fil des siècles la doctrine catholique, la doctrine de l'Église, la doctrine officielle,
vont dire en fait Jésus n'a jamais ri.
Alors effectivement, le rire de Jésus n'est jamais mentionné dans les évangiles, donc on en a déduit qu'il n'avait jamais ri.
Et en revanche, on a ri de Jésus. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on s'était moqué de Jésus lors de son procès, lors de sa passion, encore une fois, les quolibets, les crachats, etc.
Les grosses blagues sur lui, t'es le roi des Juifs, etc, etc. Et donc en fait, les premiers théologiens vont dire le rire, Jésus n'a jamais ri, on a ri de Jésus.
Ils vont dire aussi Jésus n'a jamais joui d'ailleurs, Jésus n'a jamais connu de femme. Ils vont en déduire que le rire est mauvais, que le rire est satanique, que le rire est diabolique. En plus de ça,
ils vont trouver qu'il y a des similitudes entre le rire et l'activité sexuelle, parce que dans l'activité sexuelle, on retrouve le même abandon à la jouissance, les mêmes secousses de l'abdomen, la même respiration haletante,
le même, la même absence de contrôle.
Et là, on touche à la virilité.
Oui, aussi, aussi. D'ailleurs, tu me parles de virilité, c'est pour cette raison que le rire va être assimilé par l'Église et donc tu le vois d'ailleurs dans toutes les représentations picturales.
Le rire, c'est la sorcière, c'est la prostituée dans l'histoire de la construction du rire en Occident.
C'est le diable.
Voilà, c'est quelque chose qui renvoie au péché et au diable. Et c'est aussi pour cette raison que c'est si mal vu, encore plus mal vu pour les femmes que pour les hommes.
Et donc vraiment, tu me demandais cette opprobre portée sur le rire. Pour moi, elle est vraiment majeure à partir de l'ère chrétienne.
C'est-à-dire que t'as une condamnation chez les Grecs et chez les Romains, mais qui concerne surtout les poètes comiques, c'est-à-dire les auteurs de comédie, mais elle s'étend pas à toute la société.
Oui, et donc la logique que tu donnais en exemple, ces théologiens du Moyen Âge vis-à-vis de pourquoi il ne faudrait pas rire en disant voilà Jésus ne rigolait pas, Jésus ne jouissait pas.
Bon, peut-être qu'ils étaient convaincus du bien-fondé de cette logique-là. Je pense que c'est assez clair que voilà, je parlais de virilité il y a quelques instants, mais il y a une forme de...
Voilà, on refuse de s'abandonner à quelque chose dont on perd le contrôle. Le contrôle, c'est important pour être des vrais hommes bien durs, bien en contrôle.
Le fait de succomber à des émotions vives, que ce soit le rire ou la passion sexuelle, etc. C'est quelque chose d'impur qu'on ne contrôle pas et ça, c'est quelque chose auquel ils avaient envie de fuir.
Et il y avait en plus de ça l'idée que finalement, se rire, par exemple, de l'Église catholique, ben c'est finalement se moquer de la création de Dieu.
Et ça, c'est un péché.
Ça, c'est le péché suprême. Mais puisque tu parles de virilité, il ne faut pas oublier que la virilité, un des marqueurs de la virilité, c'est la transgression de la norme, justement.
Plus l'Église va interdire le rire aux moines, plus les hommes vont s'emparer du rire comme un marqueur de virilité triomphale. Et donc-
On dépasse la règle.
Voilà.
On est rebelle.
Exactement. Et donc le rire dans la tradition occidentale, tu as aussi ce rire des guerriers, le rire du triomphe du guerrier.
D'ailleurs, on l'a déjà chez Homère, c'est-à-dire le rire sarcastique et narquois de triomphe.
Sardonien.
Voilà. Sardon... oui, exactement.
Sardonique, pardon.
Sardonien ou sardonique, on peut dire les deux. Et effectivement, ce rire de cruauté, en fait, le hahaha, je t'ai bien eu.
Et puisque tu parles de virilité, je ne résiste pas, tu me connais un peu, à rebondir parce que ne serait-ce que le terme de blague, ça vient de la blague à tabac.
La blague à tabac, bon, on sait que le tabac, c'était un privilège masculin. C'était très mal porté de fumer jusqu'au vingtième siècle pour une femme et c'était vraiment un apanage viril.
Et la blague à tabac qui se gonfle et qui se dégonfle comme une blague où tu vois la blague, ça monte, ça monte, ça monte et puis tout à coup, ça se dégonfle, comme la bourse en fait.
Et ce qui est intéressant de voir, c'est que même si l'Église a condamné le rire, le rire reste quand même un marqueur de virilité, alors que pour les femmes, c'est très mal perçu.
Il faut rappeler quand même qu'au dix-neuvième siècle, les femmes n'avaient pas le droit d'assister à une comédie.
Donc si elles le faisaient, soit elles devaient se déguiser en homme, c'est ce que faisait George Sand, soit elles devaient aller dans des loges très haut perchées, et se cacher derrière leur éventail.
Mais le parterre très bruyant où d'ailleurs on pouvait fumer, était réservé aux hommes. Et là, on pouvait glousser, rire à gorge déployée.
Il y a un livre très intéressant de Sabine Melchior-Bonnet qui s'appelle Le Rire des femmes où elle montre que le rire, en fait, c'est interdit aux femmes parce qu'il offense
trois qualités, trois attributs qui sont naturalisés ou essentialisés comme féminins.
Il y a la beauté d'abord, parce que le rire, ça distend les traits du visage, donc c'est laid. Surtout qu'à l'époque, on avait des dents, on n'avait pas des belles dents, donc il fallait surtout pas les montrer.
Donc au moins un rire bouche close et les yeux baissés minimum. Deuxièmement, ça offense la bienséance parce que souvent le rire, ben c'est l'obscénité, c'est la trivialité.
Et comme on l'a dit, il y a ces espèces de secousses,
organiques qui rappellent l'acte sexuel. Et enfin, ça offense la vertu puisque souvent le rire est moqueur, donc malveillant, et que, comme chacun sait, la femme est tenue à être douce, gentille, vertueuse, patiente, voilà.
Donc elle ne doit pas se moquer de son prochain.
Et pour toutes ces raisons, le fait qu'aujourd'hui, depuis un peu moins d'un siècle, les femmes remplissent des salles de théâtre,
de spectacles parfois immenses comme Forestier ou Blanche Gardin, ben c'est une vraie révolution culturelle.
C'est vraiment quelque chose qui aurait été inimaginable au XIXᵉ siècle.
Oui, ce qui est assez passionnant, je trouve, avec l'exemple médiéval, c'est ce changement radical.
On parlait, voilà, de ces excès, ces carnavals, ces rires, et tout d'un coup, voilà, on bascule dans la répression.
Voilà, il y a toute une série d'interdictions qui ont eu lieu, par exemple. Qu'est-ce que ces interdictions révèlent sur le rapport du pouvoir en général et dans ce cas-ci, du pouvoir ecclésiastique, au rire, voilà, rire irrévérencieux ?
Est-ce que c'est pas finalement quelque chose qui montre que le rire, ça échappe au pouvoir ? C'est quelque chose qui n'arrive pas à être contrôlé.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est de voir qu'à la Renaissance, il va y avoir une volonté de réformer le rire et que le rire va traverser une crise profonde.
C'est-à-dire que ce gros rire médiéval un peu grossier et vengeur va être condamné, parce qu'en fait, il devient trop menaçant pour la royauté et pour l'Église.
Parce qu'il y a la... L'Église et la royauté sont déjà très menacées par la réforme protestante. Et du coup, le désordre et la débauche...
Le Moyen Âge, c'était un monde qui était assez confiant dans ses propres valeurs, dans ses normes, dans ses croyances.
Donc en fait, le Moyen Âge, il pouvait s'offrir le luxe de s'autoparodier et de tout désacraliser. Alors que le monde de la Renaissance, au contraire, c'est un monde inquiet, dubitatif, c'est un monde tragique.
L'Europe est ensanglantée par les guerres de religion entre catholiques et les protestants. Et en fait, la chrétienté est en péril. Donc ça devient
beaucoup trop menaçant de continuer à la fragiliser. Donc au Moyen Âge,
toutes ces parodies dans les grandes fêtes populaires étaient des sortes de marques d'approbation de l'ordre, puisque comme je te le disais, ces fêtes avaient vocation à se terminer.
Et quand elles se terminaient, c'était le rétablissement de l'ordre. Et donc si tu veux, l'envers grotesque de la vie servait à en légitimer l'endroit.
Mais à la Renaissance, toutes ces railleries envers l'Église sont suspectées de venir nourrir l'hérésie protestante.
Donc là, à partir de la Renaissance, on va considérer que ce qu'il faut, enfin l'heure est plus au solennel, au majestueux, au grandiose.
Et on va voir que les autorités civiles et religieuses vont étouffer le rire. Il va y avoir une sorte de police du rire.
On va commencer à interdire les fêtes, à interdire les mascarades, à pourchasser les bouffons, etc., etc.
Mais c'est intéressant de voir que c'est vraiment une crise du rire, quoi.
Mh. Et une crainte. Enfin, c'est vraiment quelque chose-
Et une crainte.
Qu'on voit comme étant un danger.
Une menace. Exactement. Oui.
Ouais.
Une menace existentielle pour le pouvoir, ouais.
Oui, donc dans ce cas-ci, c'est le pouvoir ecclésiastique.
C'est politique parce que l'un est assis sur l'autre. Si tu veux, la loyauté de droit divin, c'est une seule et même chose un peu.
Donc quand tu menaces l'Église, tu menaces aussi le pouvoir-
Mh.
En France.
Voilà. Quelques... Donc là, on arrive à la Renaissance, hein, le XVIᵉ siècle. Tout doucement, il y a ce moment où, par exemple, la Sorbonne, qui est un peu le,
oui, le bras idéologique du pouvoir catholique, qui à ce moment-là a condamné les romans Pantagruel et Gargantua de Rabelais, en les jugeant obscènes et irrévérencieux.
Oui.
Cet exemple-là, qu'est-ce que cette censure-là révèle des limites de la tolérance du pouvoir religieux vis-à-vis de la satire, oui ?
La Renaissance, malgré à ce moment-là, oui, cette renaissance du XVIᵉ siècle, cet humanisme du XVIᵉ siècle, qu'est-ce que ça dit, cette censure-là ?
Ben en fait, ça renvoie un peu à ce que Norbert Elias a appelé la civilisation des mœurs, et où il montre qu'à partir du XVIᵉ siècle, on va chercher beaucoup à civiliser nos courtisans, civiliser les mœurs, civiliser le rire donc.
Et civiliser le rire, ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'il va falloir à la fois le moraliser et le domestiquer. C'est-à-dire domestiquer, c'est lui apprendre les bonnes manières et le moraliser, c'est l'orienter vers les bonnes valeurs.
Donc c'est un peu ça cette idée, c'est que la civilité, c'est qu'à partir du XVIᵉ siècle, on va être obsédé par de nouvelles règles de convenance.
Qui sont exigées par la sociabilité de la vie de la cour en fait. C'est qu'autrefois, enfin c'est ce que montre Norbert Elias, c'est que
autrefois, donc au Moyen Âge, on avait des seigneurs féodaux qui régnaient sur leurs terres en maître incontesté, qui passaient leur temps à guerroyer entre eux et qui étaient finalement assez
indépendants à l'égard du pouvoir royal.
Et tout à coup, à partir de la vie de cour,
ils sont transformés en une espèce d'assemblée pacifique de courtisans qui doivent obéir de manière aveugle au roi et qui doivent surtout passer leur temps à rechercher les faveurs très arbitraires,
du souverain.
Donc, en fait, toutes les vertus guerrières et ce rire fort, ce rire grossier, c'est... Tout ce qui était porté aux nues,
au Moyen Âge doit au contraire s'effacer devant ces nouvelles règles de civilité qui sont la politesse, la discrétion, la tempérance, l'autodiscipline, la vertu, etc.
Donc c'est surtout ça que ça raconte.
Et ce que ça montre aussi, c'est que ça ne s'installe jamais vraiment sur la durée. Enfin, ça ne marche pas. On n'arrive pas à réprimer le rire et à le faire disparaître.
On le rend secret, éventuellement.
Oui, ben, on peut le condamner dans des livres, parce qu'en fait, là, on parle de quoi ? On parle de traités de civilité, notamment d'Érasme ou de Castiglione, donc qui...
C'est dans les manuels. Disons que ce sont des préceptes. C'est voilà comment et voilà ce à quoi il faudrait tendre.
Mais en réalité, ça ne sert absolument à rien de
moraliser le rire. C'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas ni le moraliser ni le domestiquer, sauf,
sauf hypocritement, en société, mais en réalité, comme ça renvoie à un besoin primaire de rire, à un besoin vital, à un besoin d'exorciser les choses et surtout, c'est souvent difficile à contrôler.
C'est dans les traités de civilité, ça veut pas pour autant dire que ça va disparaître.
voilà, et on sait très bien que quand on cherche à domestiquer quelque chose, on a, par effet de balancier, au contraire, une tendance à amplifier ça.
Par exemple, je sais pas,
dans mon livre, je montre qu'on aura beau vouloir domestiquer les mœurs de la cour, ben on se rend compte que la cour est aussi toujours aussi friande de blagues scatologiques, qu'elle rate pas une occasion pour
rire de choses, voilà, de l'obscénité.
Donc, on parle de principes opposés à la réalité, voilà.
Et donc, si je fais un immense, voilà cet immense bond en avant dans le temps et que j'arrive,
voilà, à une époque qui se rapproche de la nôtre, XXᵉ siècle, et qu'on observe des régimes fascistes de plus en plus oppressants, par exemple celui de l'Allemagne nazie,
comment est-ce que l'humour des personnes opprimées, par exemple, donc dans le cadre de l'Allemagne, les Juifs, était perçu, était géré par, par exemple, ce dictateur Hitler ?
Bon, alors j'ai pas énormément de données là-dessus. Simplement, il y a une phrase dans le discours d'Hitler du 30 janvier 1939,
où il dit : « Je présume que le rire sonore de la juiverie en Allemagne s'étrangle à présent dans sa gorge.
» Je pense qu'il s'est vraiment trompé parce que plus la situation devenait apocalyptique pour les Juifs, plus, au contraire, ils avaient besoin de rire de leur propre déréliction.
Et de toute façon, rien n'empêchera jamais les Juifs de rire et surtout de rire d'eux-mêmes. Et ça, si on peut en parler deux secondes, c'est quand même intéressant de voir à quel point,
le, enfin le lien étroit entre autodérision et judéité et le-
Mmh.
La place énorme que l'humour occupe dans la culture juive.
Et la place énorme que l'humour juif occupe de manière générale dans l'humour actuel aujourd'hui, en Occident, à New York en particulier.
On pense à Saturday Night Live et compagnie. C'est très très marqué par les Juifs new-yorkais, tout à fait, oui.
Tout à fait. Et il faut pas oublier que la grâce de Dieu est descendue sur Terre par une plaisanterie pour les Juifs, parce que l'alliance de Dieu avec Abraham, elle s'est nouée autour de ce fameux rire.
Quand on apprend à Abraham et à Sarah, qui sont âgés de cent ans pour Abraham, quatre-vingt-dix ans pour Sarah : « Vous allez avoir un enfant.
» Abraham s'effondre au sol et Sarah, elle, elle rigole, elle est hilare et elle lui dit : « Mais enfin, c'est pas possible, moi, toute ridée comme je suis, comment veux-tu que ça m'arrive ?
», etc. Et en souvenir de ce rire, leur fils s'appellera Isaac, qui signifie Dieu rit.
Mmh.
Donc voilà, et c'est Elie Wiesel qui dira, voilà : « Ce
nom de Dieu rit d'Isaac, c'est une façon de rappeler aux survivants de l'histoire juive à venir qu'il est possible, je le cite, hein, de souffrir et de désespérer toute une vie sans pour autant renoncer à pratiquer l'art du rire.
» Hein, et donc c'est vrai que l'humour juif, c'est un art de rire de soi, comme en sorte un peu pour devancer ou désamorcer la moquerie anti-juive.
Mais bon, donc, pour en revenir à Hitler, ben il s'était bien trompé parce que justement, il y a des écrits qui montrent, par exemple, Michel Borwicz qui a écrit Les Écrits des condamnés à mort sous l'Occupation.
Il y a aussi une écrivaine roumano-hongroise qui s'appelle Anna Novac et qui a parlé de sa détention à Auschwitz.
Et les deux ont dit qu'il y avait beaucoup de blagues qui s'échangeaient à Auschwitz. Alors évidemment- Pas à certains moments, j'imagine, mais
Oui, ils se demandaient à quoi ressemblait la vie outre wagon, des choses comme ça.
Voilà, des choses comme ça.
Alors, en France, on dit wagon, pardon.
Oui, ben, c'est : « Oui, crois-tu dans la vie d'outre wagon ? » Ou : « Ne t'inquiète pas, on va se retrouver un jour en tant que petit savon dans une devanture », etc.
Bon, c'est assez sordide, mais c'est de l'autodérision. Et effectivement, je pense que plus la situation est désespérée, plus le rire est nécessaire en fait.
Et il y a aussi l'exemple de Germaine Tillion,
qui était, elle, résistante. Et quand elle a été à Buchenwald, elle a créé une espèce d'opérette revue comique
avec ses codétenus pour tourner en dérision la barbarie nazie, pour se moquer des capos, pour se moquer de la mauvaise nourriture, pour se moquer de la mauvaise literie, des morpions, etc.
Et donc voilà, on voit que rien n'empêche jamais le rire, en fait, d'éclore, puisque le rire, il émane de l'instinct de survie.
Oui. Alors, tu faisais le lien entre ce rire, cet humour et finalement une certaine humilité de la culture et du peuple juif.
Voilà, ce peuple qui a été donc opprimé et persécuté depuis la nuit des temps, enfin depuis une éternité. Donc un lien assez clair entre, voilà, le statut qui était le leur, cette humilité et cet humour.
Inversement, voilà, dans l'histoire plus récente, et c'est, voilà, on va tout doucement s'attarder sur des questions plus récentes de l'actualité.
Je sens que tu glisses vers Guillaume Meurice.
Mais de manière générale, voilà, les blagues sur la judéité, par exemple, sont compliquées. Ces dernières années, il y a un contexte très fragile, voilà, un petit champ de mines, ce sujet.
et voilà, ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'on parlait des Juifs comme étant, comme ayant énormément d'autodérision. Effectivement, ce jeune, ce charmant garçon, Guillaume Meurice,
qui donc, tout le monde a entendu l'histoire, hein, mais chroniqueur à ce moment-là, avec
Charline Vanhoenacker et Alexis Zarca, sur France Inter,
a fait une blague sur Benyamin Netanyahou en disant que c'était un nazi circoncis.
Sans prépuce.
Ah pardon, un nazi sans prépuce.
Une sorte de nazi sans prépuce.
Une sorte.
Ah oui, mais chaque mot compte.
Oui, oui, tous les mots comptent. Tu as raison.
Mais donc, voilà. Et c'est intéressant de voir qu'on est apparemment arrivé à un moment donné où une blague qui, comment dire,
tangente, qui touche vaguement à la judéité sans la frapper directement,
devient inacceptable.
Une affaire d'État.
Qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de cet épisode ?
Une affaire d'État. Bon, alors, il y a beaucoup de choses à dire là-dessus.
Oui.
Ce qu'il faut rappeler, comme je le disais tout à l'heure, c'est que c'est jamais une affaire d'énoncé, mais une affaire d'énonciation.
C'est-à-dire, dans quel contexte, qui émet la blague, qui est la cible et quelle est l'intention. Alors, dans le cas de Guillaume Meurice, le contexte, c'est vrai que c'était un contexte juste après le 7 octobre.
Ou peu de temps après, dans les mois qui ont suivi.
Voilà. Et c'était une époque où il y a eu, on ne savait pas encore que c'étaient les Russes qui avaient tagué plein d'étoiles juives dans les rues de Paris.
En fait, ça, maintenant, on sait que c'était-
Oui, on a... Les vidéos sont sorties par après.
Voilà. Donc à l'époque, on était dans un climat d'abattement total sur le 7 octobre et puis de regain d'antisémitisme, enfin supposé.
C'est-à-dire que voilà, ce qu'on entendait tout le temps au journal télévisé, c'était : antisémitisme revient, le 7 octobre, etc.
Bon, donc dans ce contexte, la blague était dangereuse. Enfin, c'était-
Ambigu peut-être.
C'était ambigu, c'était une prise de risque. Alors, rétrospecti-- bon, mais déjà, pour moi, si on regarde le contenu à proprement parler de la blague, ça ne visait pas les Juifs.
Enfin, en tout cas, c'est mon interprétation. Ça ne visait pas les Juifs. Ça visait... C'était une blague offensive envers Netanyahou,
qui en l'occurrence a prouvé depuis qu'il était un criminel de guerre sans foi ni loi, irrespectueux du droit international.
Et je pense, autant on doit faire très attention avec l'humour quand la cible est vulnérable. Or, au contraire, je pense qu'on doit être moins attentif quand la cible est puissante.
En l'occurrence ici, ce qui est tendancieux, enfin, ou dangereux, disons, c'est que derrière Netanyahou, il y avait les Juifs qui sont de fait une population stigmatisée vulnérable.
Donc ça pouvait être mal interprété. De là à ce que ça lui coûte sa place, et que ça lui vaille un procès qu'il a d'ailleurs gagné.
Voilà, on est tombé dans une forme, d'après moi, d'excès. Mais je... C'est mon opinion. Mais maintenant, en fait- Si tu veux, il y a un autre exemple que je trouve qui va peut-être clarifier ma pensée.
Parce que fondamentalement, ce que j'ai appelé le pacte humoristique, c'est-à-dire, je veux dire, on peut dire rire de tout, faire toutes les blagues qu'on veut, se moquer de tout le monde, etc.
À condition que ce soit fait avec humour. Et l'humour, c'est dans quel contexte, qui est l'émetteur, qui est la cible, qui est le récepteur et dans quel état d'esprit.
C'est ça.
Et un même énoncé
n'a pas la même portée dans un contexte ou dans un autre. Il y a un exemple qui concerne les Juifs et que je trouve plus facile à traiter parce qu'il est un peu plus loin de nous et puis il est beaucoup plus clair.
C'est l'exemple du sketch de Desproges, son fameux sketch dit sur les Juifs, mais qui est en fait un sketch sur les antisémites, un sketch qui commence par : « On me dit que des Juifs se sont glissés dans la salle.
Ah oui, il ne faut pas oublier quand même que les Juifs ont été très hostiles au régime nazi. Et puis j'irai aux douches si je veux.
Et qu'est-ce que c'est que ce train pas confortable ? » Enfin, des propos, des énoncés absolument ignobles.
Mais Desproges n'entamait ce sketch qu'au bout d'une heure de spectacle, au bout d'une heure. Et cette heure lui avait laissé tout le temps d'établir un climat d'innocuité, un climat de confiance.
Et au bout de cette heure, on savait qu'il allait se moquer non pas des Juifs déportés, mais de l'antisémite.
Il allait se moquer de l'antisémite qui parle du Juif.
Alors, dans ce contexte-là, mais quand, en revanche, quand ce sketch a été extrait de son contexte pour être placardé sur le site ultranationaliste, ultra xénophobe et ultra antisémite d'Alain Soral,
sans aucune précaution oratoire, là, pour le coup, là, c'était donné à entendre pour ce que c'était, c'est-à-dire un énoncé antisémite.
Donc, c'est pour ça que c'est complexe. Il y a toute cette affaire de contexte qui est hyper importante. Et dans le cas-
Ça devenait un énoncé antisémite dans ce contexte-là.
Exactement. Là, ça devenait un énoncé.
Et d'ailleurs, les filles de Desproges
ont demandé que ce sketch soit retiré du site parce qu'elles ne cautionnaient absolument pas l'instrumentalisation antisémite qui était faite à partir d'un sketch qui se moquait des antisémites.
Donc c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure, on disait : c'est une ligne de crête hyper étroite. Effectivement, là, Guillaume Meurice, il a joué sur du velours ou sur des clous.
Je ne sais pas comment il faut dire, mais c'était très, c'était très risqué, c'était très dangereux. En l'occurrence, il a clivé vraiment le pays.
Il y avait les gens qui étaient comme moi, tout aussi révulsés par l'antisémitisme, mais qui considéraient que cet énoncé ne pouvait pas relever de l'antisémitisme.
Ça a d'ailleurs été aussi le jugement du tribunal, hein, qui a dit : « Bah non, c'est pas antisémite, donc ça ne tombe pas sous le coup de la loi.
L'injure n'est pas caractérisée, les infractions ne sont pas caractérisées. Circulez, il n'y a rien à voir. » Donc ça, c'est ce qu'a dit le tribunal.
Après, la direction de France Inter et surtout la présidence de Radio France, parce que c'est surtout de là-haut que c'est venu, a jugé que dans le contexte,
qui était celui du post-7 octobre, ça n'était pas judicieux sur le service public de diffuser ça.
Bon, c'est leur décision, mais vraiment le-
Il a réénoncé la même blague un mois plus tard, dans l'émission et après avoir reçu donc un avertissement-
Oui, exactement.
De la part de la direction.
Exactement.
Et comme il a refait la même blague-
Oui.
Il s'est fait licencier.
Est-ce que... Bon, là, on s'éloigne de plus en plus du rire avec la question que je vais poser maintenant, mais est-ce que ce n'était pas aussi dans un contexte un petit peu politique aussi ?
Le, voilà, le... Donc, la présidente de Radio France à ce moment-là, c'était Adèle Van Reeth...
Non. Alors, Adèle Van Reeth, c'est la directrice de France Inter.
D'accord.
Et la présidence de Radio France, c'est Sibyle Veil.
Ah oui, tout à fait.
Et d'après mes sources, c'était surtout Sibyle Veil qui était en colère. Adèle Van Reeth a défendu Guillaume Meurice en tout cas au début.
D'accord, ok.
Parce qu'elle s'entendait bien avec lui et qu'effectivement, elle n'était pas plus choquée que ça. Mais ça, c'est venu de...
D'après mes informations, encore une fois, c'est venu de tout en haut de la présidence de Radio France.
Ah oui, ok.
Et...
Donc c'était bien politique.
Oui, c'est-- oh bah, c'était cent pour cent politique. Évidemment, c'était à cent pour cent politique. En fait, quand il a réitéré sa blague, c'est ce qui lui a été reproché.
Il l'a réitéré pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, le tribunal a décrété que les infractions n'étaient pas constituées.
Donc, en fait, ça ne relevait pas de l'injure antisémite. Donc, comme j'ai dit, circulez, il n'y a rien à voir.
Donc là, il est revenu sur l'antenne, il a dit : « Bon, c'est la première fois que je vais faire cette blague en toute légalité.
Voilà, je la refais puisque maintenant, c'est une blague légale. » Donc, bah ça, c'était tout à fait du Guillaume Meurice, c'était de la provoc'.
Mais encore une fois, on lui a demandé, ce que la présidence de Radio France lui a demandé, c'était de s'excuser. Et c'est ce qu'il a refusé.
Parce qu'il a dit : « En fait, si je dois m'excuser à chaque fois que j'offense quelqu'un, mais ma chronique va s'appeler pardon, pardonnez-moi.
» Parce que c'est quand même pour ça qu'il était payé, c'était pour faire de la provoc'. Et justement, quand Adèle Van Reeth a pris la direction de cette antenne, elle a dit : « On va continuer à titiller les interdits.
» Bon, titiller les interdits, ça veut bien dire qu'on va aller là où effectivement, on va subvertir des codes, même au risque de choquer ou de heurter.
Si tu veux, on peut défendre la position de Radio France en disant voilà, il y avait un contexte qui était tellement effroyable.
C'est vrai, il faut rappeler quand même que ça a été quelque chose de terrifiant, les massacres du sept octobre.
Maintenant, un an et demi après, quand on voit à quel point les massacres à Gaza, il y a plus de mots.
Je ne sais pas si on peut... 'fin, on verra bien ce que disent les juristes sur le mot génocide. Mais enfin, en tout cas, à tout le moins, on peut parler de crime contre l'humanité.
'fin, je pense que ça fait pas un pli. Ces massacres sont un scandale absolu, l'effondrement absolu du droit international.
Donc rétrospectivement, on se dit attends, on a fait une petite blague sur un type qui sera jugé par l'histoire peut-être aussi nocif qu'un Staline ou qu'un Bachar el-Assad.
Voilà donc, où est le mal ?
C'est ça qui est curieux dans la formule de dire il faut s'excuser, mais on-
Oui.
fait de la cible de la blague. C'est, voilà, c'est quelqu'un qui a été condamné par la Cour pénale internationale. Donc c'est doublement curieux.
Tout à fait. Non, mais c'est là qu'on voit à quel point l'humour, c'est loin d'être une affaire simple et ça a tout d'une affaire politique.
Là, on voit vraiment qu'une simple blague peut devenir une affaire d'État.
Mh.
C'est qu'on a voulu se débarrasser de lui parce qu'il a été soupçonné de nourrir l'antisémitisme en France. Et on peut lui reprocher ce qu'on veut, mais il est tout sauf antisémite.
Moi, je le connais personnellement, c'est tout sauf un antisémite. Et ça, on peut faire la même remarque pour Blanche Gardin, hein.
Blanche Gardin, moi aussi, je la soutiens complètement dans sa démarche. Je veux dire, elle a... Je ne sais pas si tu connais le sketch de Blanche Gardin qui lui est reproché.
C'est une sorte de pipe, c'est ça ?
Non.
C'est pas celle-là.
C'est pas ça. Non, c'est... En fait, elle a fait une espèce de parodie des Alcooliques anonymes, où c'était les antisémites anonymes-
Ah oui.
avec Aymeric Lompret. Donc elle arrive sur scène et puis elle dit : « Ben moi, je viens, depuis le sept octobre, je suis antisémite et en fait, oui, je suis antisémite ».
Et en fait, ce qu'elle veut dire dans ce sketch au second degré, c'est : on me traite d'antisémite dès que je dis qu'il y a un massacre à Gaza.
Mh.
Or je veux pouvoir le dire. Et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu une espèce de chape de plomb. Je ne sais pas ce qu'il en est en Belgique, mais en France, il y a eu une espèce d'interdit complet pendant des mois et des mois, partout dans les médias.
On n'avait pas le droit de dire qu'Israël était en train de commettre un massacre. Parce qu'Israël était juste en train de se défendre.
Donc, au nom de son droit à se défendre, ah ben on était tous antisémites, voilà. Moi, je peux te dire personnellement, j'ai épousé un Juif, donc j'ai la moitié de ma famille qui est juive.
Je pense vraiment, en plus des petits-enfants de déportés. Donc vraiment, on peut m'accuser de beaucoup de choses, sauf d'être antisémite.
L'antisémitisme me fait horreur.
Mais en l'occurrence, j'ai envie de défendre et Blanche Gardin et Guillaume Meurice parce que je pense qu'on leur a fait un faux procès et qu'ils ont simplement dénoncé une politique barbare de l'armée israélienne,
et non pas le peuple juif.
Et d'ailleurs, la meilleure façon de les défendre, c'est qu'aujourd'hui de dire qu'il y a beaucoup de Juifs, y compris en Israël,
qui sont horrifiés par ce qui se passe à Gaza et qui soutiennent absolument plus ou pas, à supposer qu'ils l'aient soutenu un jour, hein, puisque la gauche israélienne n'a jamais aimé Netanyahou.
Donc voilà, on s'éloigne peut-être un peu de notre sujet, mais je pense que moi, ces remises en perspective et ces petites mises au point, je trouve qu'il faut oser les faire parce qu'on est tous un peu
silenciés, forcés au silence et on est tous un peu, 'fin, lâches.
Tu es en train de dire qu'on ne peut plus rien dire, Olivia ?
Non. Alors non.
Tu as dit nous sommes tous un petit peu forcés au silence.
Non, mais-
C'est un peu plus long, mais...
Sur ces questions-là, non. Alors le on peut plus rien dire, c'est une phrase qui m'énerve beaucoup aussi.
Je sais bien, je plaisante.
Parce que la preuve, c'est que Guillaume Meurice, il peut parfaitement dire ce qu'il veut sur Radio Nova.
Oui, en effet, il a changé de cabri.
Voilà. Et Radio Nova, honnêtement, il y a vraiment aucune censure, hein. Donc ils y vont très largement. Donc il faut arrêter avec le on peut plus rien dire.
C'est qu'il y a certaines antennes où effectivement, c'est plus compliqué de dire certaines choses.
Mais il y a d'autres podiums, d'autres antennes.
Il y a d'autres lieux pour les dire. Et en fait, quand on dit on peut plus rien dire. Moi, si tu m'emmènes sur ce terrain, je suis inécoutable parce que ça dépend à quel niveau.
C'est-à-dire, si tu prends l'aspect, si tu dis on peut plus rien dire, il s'agit d'une censure juridique. C'est complètement faux.
La preuve d'ailleurs, un, Guillaume Meurice n'a pas été condamné. Les humoristes le sont très rarement. Il y a même Guy Bedos qui a traité Nadine Morano de conne.
Elle lui a fait un procès, elle a perdu. Donc, si tu veux, dès lors qu'il s'agit de comiques, en tout cas en France, les tribunaux ont une conception très libérale de la liberté d'expression.
Et c'est rare que, vraiment rarissime qu'une blague soit condamnée. C'est arrivé à Dieudonné.
Oui, voilà, c'est l'exemple qu'on cite.
Bon, c'est à peu près tout. Meurice s'en est sorti, Blanche Gardin aussi donc. On peut plus rien dire sur le plan juridique, c'est faux.
En revanche, ce qui est vrai, c'est qu'il y a une pression économico-médiatique sur certains supports, sur certains médias qui aujourd'hui sont, ben je pense aux médias Bolloré par exemple, qui sont voilà, on les connaît.
Effectivement, sur ces antennes-là, on est- effectivement, il y a ceux qui ont aujourd'hui effectivement le droit,
le pouvoir en fait, parce que c'est un pouvoir économique de suspendre, de ne pas diffuser, d'interdire, de refuser certains propos, etc.
Ce sont ceux qui tiennent les cordons de la bourse. Donc là oui, il y a une— mais c'est pas une censure juridique, c'est plutôt un pouvoir discrétionnaire de diffuser ou pas diffuser.
Voilà, on va parler comme ça.
Oui. Et ce sont justement ceux-là qui vont le plus souvent se plaindre du fait qu'on ne peut plus rien dire. Donc il y a une espèce de-
Exactement.
D'ironie, d'autocontradiction, de victimisation en se plaignant des gens qui se victimisent. Enfin, c'est l'absurde total.
Il y a un mot qui vient de me sortir. Enfin, j'ai vu ça l'autre jour dans Le Monde, c'est le braillonnement.
C'est-à-dire, on braille
au sens de gueuler, au sens de crier, sur le fait qu'on est bâillonné. Donc en fait, on a toutes les antennes possibles,
et on passe notre temps, ils passent leur temps sur certaines antennes, les antennes du groupe Bolloré, pour ne pas les nommer, notamment CNews.
Ils passent leur temps à dire : « Oh, la liberté d'expression n'existe plus, on peut plus rien dire, etc. » Ce sont eux qui censurent les premiers les propos qui ne leur conviennent pas.
Et dans leur bouche, on peut plus rien dire. Ça a un sens très précis. Ça veut dire : « Oh aujourd'hui, le politiquement correct », qu'ils appellent les woke, nous empêche de continuer à répandre
nos opinions fallacieuses, comme par exemple qu'il y a pas de problème de climat.
Ben si on a envie de-- c'est une opinion, on a le droit de dire qu'il n'y a pas de problème de climat, que les écolos nous font chier.
On a le droit de le dire, c'est une opinion. On a le droit de le dire que les trans, c'est une idéologie dangereuse pour la jeunesse.
On a le droit de le dire si on veut. Et ceux-là mêmes qui ont ces antennes passent leur temps à dire qu'ils sont opprimés et qu'on leur interdit de parler.
Or, en fait, ils diffusent partout, sans arrêt, sur les réseaux sociaux et sur leurs réseaux, des opinions nauséabondes, délétères, dangereuses, la fabrique des fake news, etc.
Donc oui, on est en plein paradoxe.
Oui, ça leur permet de prendre la position de la victime dans le débat. Et cette position-là, voilà, ça leur permet une rhétorique très puissante.
C'est très efficace de se poser en victime. On est tout de suite beaucoup plus convaincant quand on est dans une position à plaindre.
Enfin, c'est tout à fait la stratégie qu'ils essayent d'opérer. On va revenir tout doucement au sujet du livre, parce que sinon, on va parler de Bolloré pendant une heure.
Ou d'Israël.
Oui, c'est ça. Écoute, si tu veux. On aurait pu également parler des attaques évidemment sur Charlie Hebdo, qui sont encore un autre sujet brûlant.
Mais on a commencé cette discussion. Tu expliquais que tout partait d'une expérience finalement personnelle, le fait que ça t'arrivait, que des fois, tu entendes une blague et un petit peu perdue, un petit peu surprise, dans l'incompréhension.
Est-ce que c'était vraiment une blague ce que je viens d'entendre ? Comment est-ce que ça se fait qu'on rit ? Est-ce que je suis censé rire maintenant ?
Est-ce que... voilà. À l'issue de ce travail, à l'issue de ce livre, à l'issue de cet essai, de tout ce
travail de documentaliste qui t'a pris quelques années, comme on l'a dit, est-ce qu'il y a des choses sur lesquelles tu as changé de perspective, des choses que ça t'a permis de mieux comprendre ?
Hmm hmm, bonne question. Alors d'abord, j'ai-
Tu peux me dire que tout ça n'a servi à rien.
Non, tout ça a énormément servi. Ce serait sinistre alors là. Non, déjà, ça a servi. Alors c'est peut-être pas du tout la réponse à ta question, mais ça m'a servi à rencontrer pas mal d'humoristes.
Ok.
Avec lesquels on m'a invitée à débattre. Donc ça, déjà, rien que pour ça, j'ai trouvé ça assez génial. Notamment Guillaume Meurice, justement.
Mais j'ai récemment fait un débat avec Gad Elmaleh sur le pouvoir du rire, Shirley Souagnon, Walid Yaar.
Voilà, et je pense que c'est des personnes que je n'aurais jamais rencontrées si j'avais pas réfléchi au rire. Donc, et j'ai appris beaucoup en discutant avec eux.
Alors, ce que m'ont appris mes recherches essentiellement, c'était toute cette fonction dont je parlais tout à l'heure, la fonction punitive, la fonction de contrôle social, la fonction de domination du rire.
Là où ça m'a aidée, c'est que ça m'a permis de beaucoup mieux comprendre ce qui faisait qu'une blague était problématique et notamment la dimension de pouvoir là-dedans.
C'est-à-dire le fait que plus on est puissant, moins on est vulnérable à la moquerie. Par exemple, Trump, pour prendre un exemple caricatural, je crois qu'il y a personne qui se fait autant vanner sur cette planète.
Est-ce que ça nuit à son pouvoir ? Absolument pas. Ça va même au contraire un peu nourrir sa légende de personnage disruptif, là, qu'il s'est lui-même créé.
Donc ça ne lui porte pas préjudice. En revanche, quand on fait des blagues sur les Arabes et les Juifs même, ou les Noirs qui sont paresseux, qui sont malhonnêtes, etc.
Ça, ce sont, on parle de populations qui sont vulnérables, qui sont déjà stigmatisées. Et donc, le sarcasme plutôt va contribuer à consolider ces stéréotypes. Donc,
tout ce qui consolide les stéréotypes peut leur porter un tort, un préjudice concret.
Parce que, ben dans la vie concrète, à force d'entendre des blagues sur les Arabes qui sont malhonnêtes, et ben un Arabe qui se présente pour louer un appartement ou pour un job, et ben il y a une suspicion.
Qu'on le veuille ou non, il va y avoir une suspicion qui est entretenue par les blagues. Donc les blagues peuvent avoir un effet délétère.
Le fait aussi que les femmes et toutes ces blagues sexistes qui ramènent tout le temps les femmes à leurs attributs érotiques, ça vise à les disqualifier.
Voilà, on est aussi un peu disqualifiés sur le marché du travail. Je pense que les blagues n'y sont pas pour rien. Donc ça veut pas dire qu'il faut plus faire de blagues sur les femmes, parce qu'il y a une façon de les faire.
Encore une fois, là, on n'a pas encore parlé du second degré.
Ah bah oui, tout à fait.
C'est un petit peu avec les blagues, la blague de Desproges qui a l'air de se moquer des Juifs, mais qui en fait se moque des antisémites.
Bon, de la même manière, parfois, on peut se moquer... Enfin, au premier degré, c'est une blague sexiste et en fait, c'est une blague qui se moque des sexistes.
Donc encore une fois, énonciation et non pas énoncé, c'est-à-dire dans quel contexte, qui fait, qui est là, qui l'entend, qui ça cible et dans quel état d'esprit.
L'état d'esprit, c'est important aussi. C'est-à-dire, est-ce que l'état d'esprit est ludique ? Est-ce que c'est juste pour rire ?
Est-ce que c'est juste pour plaisanter ? Est-ce que c'est pour de faux ? Ou est-ce que ça vise vraiment à attaquer, à offenser ?
Et donc le même propos peut être pris au premier, enfin peut être au premier ou au deuxième degré. Donc, encore une... il y a aussi un autre paramètre, c'est est-ce qu'il y a de l'autodérision là-dedans ou pas ?
Parce que moi, je pense qu'on peut plus facilement se moquer de quelqu'un quand on accepte de se moquer de soi-même. Donc c'est tout ça, l'humour.
Humour, humilité, ça va ensemble, autodérision. Donc moi, ça m'a appris quand même plus facilement à distinguer genre un trait d'humour et un sarcasme qui n'a rien d'humoristique.
Ça m'a appris aussi, ça m'a permis de dire pourquoi une blague sur... Alors là, tu vas te sentir directement visé, hein.
Sur les Belges ?
Pourquoi je pense qu'une blague sur les Belges-
J'allais te poser la question, justement.
Eh ben oui. Eh ben moi, je pense qu'une blague sur les Belges ou sur les Suisses ou par exemple quand on prend leur accent, certes, ça conforte, ça consolide des stéréotypes, des préjugés.
D'accord. Mais c'est moins grave pour moi-
C'est pas préjudice.
...qu'une blague qui porte sur les Arabes, les Juifs ou les Noirs, parce que là, on perpétue un stigmate.
Et stigmate, tu sais, ça vient de stigma-
La tache.
...c'est la marque au fer rouge. Ouais, la marque au fer rouge avec laquelle on marquait la peau des esclaves.
Et perpétuer un cliché comme, ben, les Suisses mangent de la raclette et du chocolat, ils ont de belles montres, les Belges, je sais même pas quelle est la...
Le cliché, c'est que les Belges sont cons, donc un petit peu quand même.
Oui, alors là, c'est vrai que c'est pas un bon exemple. Mais bon, les Belges sont cons, c'est vrai que c'est préjudiciable.
Mais oui, c'est vrai. Alors c'est vrai que c'est pas, c'est vrai que... Mais c'est plus-
Il va falloir rééditer ton livre, Olivia.
Oui, alors on va rester sur les Suisses. C'est vrai que les blagues sur les Belges, ça doit leur porter préjudice.
Alors effectivement, je désolidarise les Suisses et les Belges. Parce que c'est vrai que les Suisses, on va jamais refuser à un Suisse un appartement parce qu'il est Suisse ou un job parce qu'il est Suisse.
Oui, ben, je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas pour les Belges non plus, mais...
Mais je pense pas. Moi, je pense que les Belges, c'est vraiment un peu des blagues, comment dire-
Mais parlons-en.
...désincarnées. C'est-à-dire que je pense pas que ce soit rattaché vraiment aux personnes belges qu'on rencontre.
C'est-à-dire, je pense pas que quand on rencontre un Belge, le premier réflexe, ce soit de se dire : il est con, bien au contraire.
Alors que la crainte viscérale de l'Arabe ou du Noir, tu la sens dans le métro. T'as des gens qui s'assoient pas à côté, tout simplement.
Alors qu'on va s'asseoir à côté d'un Belge sans problème dans un restaurant. Donc les Belges, c'est peut-être...
Je crois que ce sera intéressant d'écouter l'expérience des Belges qui se rendent en France de temps en temps. C'est pas toujours hyper accueillant. Le-
C'est vrai ? Bon.
Ben, bon, des petites remarques, des petites blagues.
Alors, on va les mettre dans la catégorie... Alors, changeons les catégories, mettons-les dans les vulnérables.
C'est intéressant d'en discuter. En fait, tout part, si j'ai bien compris, hein, de ce qu'on m'a expliqué, du fait que c'était vraiment autrefois les,
tu sais les Belges qui n'étaient pas forcément très éduqués au sud de la Wallonie, qui travaillaient dans les mines et qui, à un moment donné, alors ça, je ne saurais plus exactement ce qui a mené à ça, mais à un moment donné,
s'est opérée une transition sociale où voilà, cette population-là, qui n'était pas forcément hyper éduquée, est arrivée dans les métropoles françaises.
Puisqu'on a fait, en fait, on a ramené du prolétariat dans certaines villes françaises et que à ce moment-là se sont rencontrées une petite bourgeoisie française bien éduquée et inversement, des Belges pas forcément
avec un grand capital culturel, un accent très différent et qu'à ce moment-là se sont installées pas mal de moqueries et de voilà...
Il y a les blagues de Coluche qui sont assez connues.
Et ce qui est devenu intéressant, c'est le fait que les Belges sont tellement bêtes, les Belges sont tellement cons, est petit à petit devenu : ah, moi, j'adore les Belges.
Ah.
Et en fait, c'est la même chose. C'est toujours un petit tapotement sur la tête. Ah. Vous êtes trop mignons les Belges, j'adore les Belges.
Oui oui oui oui oui oui, c'est comme les gens qui ne peuvent pas s'empêcher de, quand ils voient un couple d'homos, de dire : Oh qu'est-ce qu'ils sont mignons.
Ils sont pas plus... tu vois.
Voilà.
Oui oui, je comprends ce que tu veux dire.
Il n'y a pas, comment dire, une construction vraiment, un système d'oppression raciale ou quelque chose comme ça derrière.
C'est vraiment quelque chose d'historique et d'installé, mais ça reste, et ça, je crois que c'est très français, ça reste un besoin de se hiérarchiser, un besoin d'installer une pyramide et de se placer au top.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Et le fait que la Belgique soit proche de la France avec la même langue pousse justement à s'en différencier d'autant plus qu'ils nous ressemblent.
Donc effectivement, chez le Français, il y a vraiment ce besoin de dominer, d'être le meilleur, et on ne peut pas se dire un surhomme sans désigner les sous-hommes.
Donc peut-être que les Belges en ont fait les frais effectivement, à leur manière.
Et-
Mais peut-être qu'elle est peut-être moins discriminatoire quand même que les blagues sur les Juifs ou les Arabes.
Bien sûr, bien sûr, ça va sans dire.
Je viens de trouver en quoi.
En fait, voilà. Voilà, je crois que c'est ça. Je connais pas bien la question que tu soulèves sur les Belges, mais il me semble, je soulevais ça à ta réflexion, il me semble que la différence, justement quand même entre,
entre la blague sur les Belges et la blague sur les Arabes, les Juifs ou les Noirs,
c'est que dans le cas des Belges, ça vise évidemment à les discréditer, mais ça n'a pas vocation à inspirer la haine, à nourrir la haine.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Et le rejet, ce qui est le propre de l'humour antisémite ou islamophobe ou raciste ou même sexiste.
C'est peut-être ça la différence, c'est que c'est une manière de les-
On n'est pas au programme du Front national.
Voilà, ouais, mais exactement. Exactement. Exactement. Bah voilà, mais ça dit tout.
Oui oui, c'est-
Ça dit tout quand même.
Oui oui, c'est pas la même chose. C'est compliqué. Voilà, c'est pas toujours très sympa.
C'est oui, c'est compliqué. Oui, c'est compliqué.
Mais donc on en revient, puisque tu parlais de ce besoin de se sentir au-dessus de tout. On en revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le lien entre l'humilité et l'autodérision et la capacité à rire.
Est-ce que les Français arrivent à rire d'eux-mêmes ou bien est-ce que sur France Inter, il faut importer des Belges et des Suisses pour rire en France ?
Alors, c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup d'humoristes belges de plus en plus. Et que quand tu dis : on adore les Belges, c'est qu'en ce moment, il y a enfin une déferlante d'humoristes belges qui ont énormément de succès, et ils sont très drôles.
Même aussi des Suisses, hein. Marina Rollman, je crois qu'elle est suisse.
Bien sûr. Thomas Wiesel, suisse aussi.
Et Thomas, absolument, absolument. Alors bon écoute, moi, je veux pas faire de généralités. Il y a une énorme diversité sur la scène comique, sur les antennes.
Oui bien sûr, bien sûr.
C'est difficile de résumer l'humour français à tel ou tel trait. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de commun entre Sofia Aram et Walid Yaïch ?
Ah oui, en effet.
Voilà, c'est quand même le grand écart, entre Gaspard Proust et Guillaume Meurice. Voilà, ils sont tous les deux Français, c'est...
Ils ont pas du tout les mêmes, la même façon de se marrer, donc...
Mais spécifiquement, vannent, les Français qui vannent les Français sur leur frenchitude, sur ce qui fait qu'ils sont français, tu vois, cette espèce d'autodérision, de pointer la blague vers soi-même.
Parce que c'est... J'ai l'impression que c'est quelque chose qu'on voit assez peu, moi, en France.
Bah écoute,
en tout cas, bon moi, si je prends,
puisqu'on parlait de Guillaume Meurice. Guillaume Meurice, maintenant, il est parti sur Radio Nova, il fait une émission du dimanche soir qui s'appelle La Dernière,
qui est d'ailleurs très intéressante parce que c'est pas du tout que de l'humour, ils ont invité-
Oui, ils invitent, tout à fait oui.
Un militant. J'ai eu la chance d'y être invitée d'ailleurs. Et ils ont des chroniqueurs qui passent leur temps à se moquer de la France.
Ah bah voilà.
Des Français, du gouvernement, bon ça, on s'en doute, à raison, à raison d'ailleurs. Il y a vraiment beaucoup à dire, mais ils se moquent aussi des Français.
Parce que bon, en fait, en France, on est, la société est très très très clivée, hein. Donc-
Oui, oui.
Aujourd'hui, quand on se moque, enfin, je veux dire, même le patriotisme, ça devient une valeur un peu réac, un peu de droite.
Oh ça, ça fait longtemps que ça l'est devenu, oui.
Oui, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que maintenant, c'est quand tu dis : les Français ne se moquent pas d'eux-mêmes. Si, parce qu'un Français qui se moque des patriotes ou du patriotisme ou du nationalisme,
c'est une façon de se moquer de la France et des Français, de la frenchitude.
Oui, la, la...
Voilà. Donc...
Le chauvinisme, oui.
Voilà, le chauvinisme. Moi, honnêtement, les humoristes qui me font rire, heureusement, n'ont pas de,
ne s'arrêtent pas, enfin, je veux dire, ils ne s'arrêtent pas devant la porte de la France en disant : Ah non, on est français, on touche pas.
Au contraire, il faut se moquer de nous-mêmes. Il y a tellement de quoi, parce que je veux dire la France est devenue tellement grotesque,
et elle s'est tellement, elle a tellement, enfin, son rôle à l'étranger est devenu maintenant tellement diminué.
En fait, la France, enfin, il y a vraiment de quoi rire, quoi, il y a vraiment de quoi se moquer. Enfin, donc, non, je pense qu'il y en a plein qui le font, hein, et qui le font très bien.
Très bien. Mais tu m'as très bien répondu. Il y a de l'autodérision en France et on s'en félicite.
Très bien Olivia, merci beaucoup pour ces plus que Septante Minutes.
Oui.
C'était un plaisir de te retrouver.
Mais écoute, moi aussi, moi aussi.
Est-ce que tu as quelque chose à promouvoir ou à... La dernière fois, c'est marrant, tu annonçais que tu n'étais sur aucun réseau social parce que tu es, je crois...
Pas une grande amatrice de technologie. Est-ce que c'est toujours le cas ? Est-ce que tu as des projets dont tu as envie de parler ?
Alors pour ce qui est des réseaux sociaux, je tiens à faire une petite mise au point. C'est que je les utilise en tant que spectatrice.
D'accord, ok.
Je suis sur Twitter, sur Facebook et sur Instagram avec un pseudonyme. Je ne publie rien,
je ne commente très rarement, mais en revanche, je regarde beaucoup ce qui s'y fait parce que sinon, je passerais vraiment à côté de mon époque, je pense, hein.
Donc, je pense qu'aujourd'hui, ne pas aller regarder ce qui se fait sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est se priver d'une grande source d'information au sens large, hein.
Ok, mais on ne te retrouvera pas dessus parce que tu... c'est ton petit secret.
Non, mais je ne veux pas-
Tu ne veux pas de harcèlement, tu ne veux pas qu'on t'embête.
D'abord, oui, j'ai pas envie qu'on m'embête, et j'ai pas envie non plus de-
D'attention.
En fait, pour moi, non, c'est pas ça. C'est que je pense que c'est un peu une aliénation au sens où-
Ah oui.
Si je commence à commenter un événement, et que je ne commente pas un autre, eh bien ne pas commenter devient un acte.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? À partir du moment où tu émets une opinion, s'il y a des sujets que tu passes sous silence, ça devient aussi un acte d'exp... le silence devient un acte d'expression.
Et donc en fait-
Ça devient une responsabilité, quoi, ça devient...
Ça devient une responsabilité, puis ça devient surtout une contrainte.
Un deuxième job. Oui, c'est ça.
Ça devient une contrainte et ça devient une aliénation. Et en fait, moi, j'aime bien de temps en temps faire la coupure, voilà.
Et par ailleurs, je sais d'expérience pour... enfin, je vois bien que quand il y a des... parce qu'il y a plein de contenus sur moi qui sont publiés, hein, par les médias qui m'invitent.
Ben je vois bien l'agressivité des commentaires dès que le sujet est féministe ou antiraciste, qui sont mes deux, enfin souvent un peu les deux sujets sur lesquels je m'exprime,
à travers le rire ou à travers d'autres sujets.
Je vois bien la violence des commentaires et j'ai pas du tout envie de la subir de plein de fois. Donc, je vais pas prêter, m'exposer à ça,
mais évidemment, je regarde ce qui se fait parce que ce serait passer à côté de beaucoup de choses sinon.
Très bien.
Alors, est-ce que j'ai quelque chose à promouvoir ? Ben écoute, j'ai une nouvelle obsession qui sont les violences faites aux enfants.
Ok, d'accord.
Voilà. Et je travaille là-dessus.
Au sens large ? Au sens...
Au sens large.
Oui, oui.
Au sens pas seulement des violences sexuelles, des violences tout court, les coups, les infanticides dont on parle très peu.
Bon, je vais me retenir de faire Septante Minutes maintenant sur les enfants, mais est-ce que tu comptes t'intéresser aussi-
Il faut que t'attendes quatre ans.
Oui, voilà.
Non, non, non, non, non, ce sera pas quatre ans là. Faut que ça aille plus vite.
Est-ce que tu as prévu dans le futur de t'intéresser à,
mais en fait, le système qui entoure les enfants, la hiérarchie qui entoure les enfants et la façon dont on considère les enfants, par exemple dans le système scolaire, de façon, voilà, très,
très hiérarchisée, très, très carcérale, très, très...
Ben il y a un mot, il y a des concepts qui sont en train d'émerger. On parle d'adultisme aujourd'hui, justement, pour... de domination adulte.
Mais évidemment, toute la difficulté, c'est de ne pas non plus tomber dans une absence complète de guide...
De discipline.
De cadre pour les enfants. Et donc c'est tout ce à quoi je suis en train de réfléchir. Bon, ce dont je suis certaine, c'est que toute violence
est contre-productive, et que la violence ne sert à rien et que ça, il faut l'éliminer à tout prix.
Mais je pense aussi que la culture de la punition n'est pas forcément la meilleure approche. Mais je te réserve...
La surprise.
Le fruit de mes réflexions. Non, non, mais en fait, je voudrais aller, ne pas mettre quatre ans parce que je voudrais...
Enfin, il y a vraiment une urgence hein. Je te donne juste deux chiffres, et après, je m'arrête là. Mais il y a en France, d'après le rapport de la Ciivise, cent soixante mille enfants victimes d'inceste par an.
Oui.
C'est colossal.
Oui, c'est...
Ça fait que sur une classe de trente gamins, il y en a trois.
Donc c'est effarant. Et un autre chiffre, moi, qui me donne envie de pleurer,
qui me fait pleurer d'ailleurs, parce que quand je lis des livres là-dessus, ça, je pleure souvent, c'est qu'il y a un enfant qui meurt tous les cinq jours, je dis bien tous les cinq jours, des coups d'un adulte.
Et ça, personne ne le dit, personne ne le sait.
En effet. Et donc ce sont des chiffres...
C'est des chiffres officiels publiés par le ministère.
Donc à l'échelle française. Ah oui, c'est...
À l'échelle française. Donc c'est un phénomène, c'est un fait social majeur,
que tout le monde ignore hein, parce que moi, quand je vois l'émotion suscitée par la mort du petit Émile en France, c'est certes bien de s'émouvoir, mais pour moi, c'est,
c'est presque un peu dangereux parce que ça voudrait dire que c'est le seul enfant qui a été tué.
Oui, c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt.
Exactement. Ça veut dire que : « Mon Dieu, un enfant est mort ». Alors qu'en fait, c'est tous les cinq jours. Il y a un petit Émile tous les cinq jours dont on ne parlera jamais, qui va mourir, qui est mort dans le plus grand silence.
Donc je trouve que c'est un scandale absolu. Tu vois, on voit apparaître des affaires comme Bétharram, etc.
Et il y a... et c'est un immense tabou. Et pour moi, c'est vraiment l'angle mort du patriarcat.
En effet, vaste sujet dont on, voilà, dont on te réservera le privilège, voilà, de l'explorer dans quelques années, mais pas quatre, dans quelque temps.
Non, non, non, parce que j'ai déjà pas mal avancé.
Ah voilà.
J'ai déjà pas mal avancé.
Dernière question avant de te quitter, est-ce que tu es une adulte, Olivia ?
Est-ce que je suis une adulte ?
Oui.
Je suis même une vieille, moi.
Ah ok. Tu as embrassé, tu as embrassé l'adultisme alors.
Eh ben, justement, j'ai beaucoup réfléchi en élevant mes propres enfants, parce que je ne suis pas naïve hein, je sais bien que tout n'est pas simple, mais en tout cas je n'ai jamais, jamais, jamais, jamais, jamais levé la main...
Était violente, oui.
...sur les enfants. Et surtout, j'ai toujours essayé. Alors, je n'ai pas été... Voilà, je pense que j'ai aussi fait bien des bêtises et bien des erreurs dans la manière de...
C'est le principe hein, c'est...
C'est le principe des erreurs.
...c'est un travail ingrat et rempli d'erreurs, ouais.
Voilà. Mais ce que j'ai toujours essayé, c'est d'établir un dialogue. En fait, quand... Forcément, on est dans la position d'autorité, mais expliquer le fondement
d'une discipline ou d'une exigence plutôt que de l'imposer par la force.
C'est-à-dire expliquer la nécessité de prendre une douche, de mettre une écharpe quand on a froid, de manger des légumes.
Expliciter les choses qui sont un peu implicites.
Expliciter, voilà, plutôt que d'imposer.
Mh.
Alors parfois, malheureusement, on a un manque de temps pour expliquer tout et tout ça n'est pas simple.
Mais et je veux pas du tout faire la morale aux parents qui souvent
font ce qu'ils peuvent et, voilà, ce n'est pas du tout facile d'être parent, mais en tout cas, essayer de déconstruire la nécessité de recourir à la violence,
et à l'autoritarisme d'une manière générale, ça me paraît nécessaire parce que je pense que c'est complètement contre-productif pour le coup et que la violence génère la violence.
C'est-à-dire un enfant qui a été élevé dans la violence va reproduire cette violence sur ses propres enfants. Et après, c'est une violence qu'on retrouve dans la société.
Et donc, je pense qu'une éducation moins violente créerait une société moins violente.
C'est une très belle conclusion. On a fait un deuxième podcast miniature à l'issue du premier. On a atteint l'heure quarante qu'on avait atteinte...
Ouh là là.
...la dernière fois en se disant : « Mais non, c'était beaucoup trop long. » On l'a fait, on l'a fait une deuxième fois, donc je vais résister.
Et je ne sais pas si les gens ont écouté.
Je vais résister à la tentation de faire maintenant une digression sur les écoles ghettosori, Montessori, etc.
Oui, on se réserve ça pour la prochaine fois.
Mais oui, voilà. Tu vas écrire un livre sur les parents ghettosori et on en reparlera. Merci beaucoup, Olivia.
Mais écoute, c'était un plaisir. J'espère que les auditeurs ont eu la patience de rester jusqu'au bout.
Pour ceux qui sont là jusqu'au bout, ben merci d'avoir écouté, et bravo.
Mais oui.
Bravo pour votre endurance.
Mais oui. Et la dernière fois, j'avais reçu de nombreuses photos de personnes qui étaient allées acheter Le mythe de la virilité.
On rappelle que cette fois-ci, c'était donc Le paradoxe du rire.
Le paradoxe.
Et si ce n'était pas toujours drôle, aux éditions Seghers.
Qui est sorti... Attendez, attends, je dois faire ma...
Ben oui.
...je dois compléter. Il est sorti en pocket.
Ah voilà.
Donc, il coûte beaucoup moins cher maintenant.
Ah oui, et il est également dispo évidemment en e-book. Merci beaucoup, Olivia.
Merci à toi, Guillaume.
À très bientôt, au revoir.
Près de six ans ont séparé nos deux conversations, mais le plaisir que j'ai eu à parler avec Olivia est resté tout aussi électrique.
Et non, Olivia, je ne dis pas ça à la fin de chaque épisode. Merci à Olivia pour la clarté, la nuance et l'intelligence de son livre.
Encore une fois, il s'agit de son essai Le paradoxe du rire aux éditions Seghers. Comme d'habitude, si cet épisode vous a plu, pensez à le partager, à le relayer autour de vous.
Si vous n'êtes toujours pas abonné à Septante Minutes Avec, bon, je vous juge un petit peu parce que je ne sais pas très bien ce qu'il vous faut de plus.
Tous les liens vers les plateformes sont en description. Vous pouvez m'écrire sur contact@septanteminutes.be. L'adresse est également en description.
contact@septanteminutes.be. Et enfin, sauf imprévu, je vous donne rendez-vous dès la semaine prochaine pour un épisode sur le sexisme avec Isabella Lenarduzzi. Ciao, ciao, ciao.